well first of all i think all of her
thoughts quite rightly with his family
and his friends and what i would say is
that look
david was a friend of everybody in
poland he will be a major void
how can we have this senior politician
who knew everybody who was the life and
soul of parliament who always wanted to
talk about his constituents always
talking about animal welfare
he was a friend to all he was
acknowledged as a senior member of
parliament but such a great guy that's
been robbed robbed of parliament again
this if you know
we can't afford for democracy to be
smashed
we've got to look at how and what has
happened here and what i want to say is
david as i say a stalwart of parliament
a great man a lovely man who stood up
for animal rights who stood up for what
he believed in a man who stood up for
the people of south end he loved being
an mp he loved serving his constituents
and he has been killed serve his
constituents i never thought i would
have that phone call again and it was
the tragic news today i'm in shock and
p's are in shock right across all
political parties the one thing is that
i can tell you now we're united in our
thoughts for david his family and
everyone who knew him and the one thing
we do know nothing will stop democracy
nothing will stop us carrying out our
duties what i've got to say is
those people who don't value the job
that we do
those people who don't support us will
not win hence why i've had my surgery
tonight
yes you uh uh clearly are uh very uh
moved and upset by this uh as so many
will be
in westminster and no doubt you'll echo
the words of uh theresa may uh when she
said that this is a sad day for
democracy
it's an awful day for democracy not only
is it sad it is very challenging for
democracy the one thing we all hold dear
we may have different political views
across the house but the one thing that
unites us we believe in the democratic
process it's so important to us it's the
value that we cherish it's what we stand
for we represent our constituents and to
be killed represent our constituents is
not
not right it's not right that somebody
wants to do the right thing by people
it's taken away from us
absolutely leaving that void in part is
not acceptable and i've got to say the
tributes will be there on monday we will
be leading with tributes to david his
life what he stood for the values that
he helped held the fact that he always
wanted to be an mp who was a great mp a
senior member of the house as i said
nobody can believe it we're all in shock
and what i've got to do is support
colleagues through this we've got to
support mps their staff and their
families and the house staff as well
they matter to me but nobody will beat
democracy democracy must survive we may
get challenged but that challenge will
never win and i've got to say david
lovely man a great man a friend to us
all
of course democracy uh will and must
survive
and questions will come won't they and
perhaps today isn't the right day for
those questions but constituency
surgeries must continue as well
how can we make them safer
well i've carried out with my surgery i
spoke to my staff tonight and said are
you comfortable carrying on with my
surgery absolutely the people of chile
expect to see the member of palm have
been meeting with them and what we've
got to do and you're quite right today
is not the day but what we will do
and we will continue to do it's always
look at security measures how we can
improve that so much obviously i won't
go into the details of what we do but
what i will say is we won't sit back on
our laurels of course we know the
challenges we've got to protect mps and
allow them to carry out their duties the
duties that the electorate put them
therefore to speak to meet and to make
sure that their views are conveyed to
parliament so i've got to say
that people who won't don't accept our
values will not win but at the moment we
don't want an immediate reaction now but
what i can tell you is of course we're
going to be looking into issues i've
been speaking with the home secretary
already we're getting reassurances out
there to mps and in furnace chief
constables up and down this country are
speaking to mps to reassure them and
it's about reassuring people at this
stage and then that do it we will take
out further measures if needed
do we need a kinder discourse some of
the language
used by politicians journalists and
others has become toxic hasn't it of
late do we need to rethink that
i always believe in nicer politics
i believe in politics
we won't agree
but what we must do is tolerate but
respect it's about respecting other
people's views and opinions that will
always matter and it's about ensuring
there is respect to the job that
politicians carry out respect from the
electorate even if they didn't vote for
them mps take up their cases they will
look after them and what i would say is
and i generally mean this that we need a
nicer politics across the world it's not
just this country but it's a better
respect for politicians politicians do
it have a duty occur to people and what
we need is as you say nicer politics
politics that look after politicians and
respect the job they do you don't have
to agree with them but in fairness they
carry out their duties they take it
seriously and you're right whether it's
the media whether it's politicians
politician we've got to re-look at this
and start making people believe in
democracy again as i said we always got
to look to nicer politics right across
the world it's so important to us all
answer lindsay very briefly uh if you
would what would be your message to
people who are thinking about being mps
and quite frankly have been scared by
what they've seen today
don't give up on that hope and the
aspiration to become a politician please
democracy needs you
we've got to make sure democracy thrives
and we can't have people who live in
fear of becoming a politician we've got
to give you support we've got to
overcome the challenges we've got to
make it a nicer place we need more
people coming into politics